is there
something you've figured out through
your journey
with psychedelics about some of the big
why questions about life
like oh like what the heck's the value
of love
um why does it suck so much that we die
and uh and for some of us maybe it's the
russian in me but
it's quite terrifying the notion of it
or the biggest why question of them all
which is
what's the meaning of it all well
um yeah what i've discovered is that um
we don't need answers to those questions
you know
that the fact that um
we can feel happy you know that we can
love that we can have
moments of happiness that's enough
you know figuring out these big
questions you can get lost in that
and you we all can come up with our
answers what's what's the meaning of
life why
why is there life why is there
consciousness but um
i don't know that we need those answers
what we know is that we're um
social creatures that um
we people other people can make us happy
by certain things we can make other
people happy
that one life is enough so this other
part about uh
why is it so um tragic that we die yeah
um i i don't think it's tragic that we
die so first off if you believe in this
collective unconscious but but but
we have an impact that lasts but i think
that
for me at least i've been of the view
that um
we should be grateful for death that
death makes life precious
that if we had an infinite amount of
time
you know i mean i'm i'm a bit of a
procrastinator about stuff
particularly things that are really you
know hard to do and you just you know
you just don't do it and then like
where'd the day go i was gonna do that
so
so if we had an infinite life we never
died um
you know would life be precious would we
do anything i don't think so so
my parents gave um
you know every jewish new year they
would they would make their uh new
year's card
and and one of the quotes was fantastic
it was just
we have to make up for the brevity of
life with the intensity
of life oh man that is good
you